The prophet Muhammad sallallah.aii
wasallam told us that whoever builds a
mosque for Allah, Allah will build for
him a sim at a house in Jenna. And we
know the great reward that will not only
be gained but rather will fill your
grave after your death. Whenever someone
prays there, whenever someone gives
shahada in the masid, whenever someone
learns something in the masid, yes, that
will be something that you'll have on
your scale.
[Music]
How are you guys doing? I'm here joined
with the main man himself, smirk to
Jenna.
>> Smirk to Jenna or whatever.
>> Well, one person that's not going to
check it out is Nessah.
>> He's probably watching this at home.
Well, I mean, I think he is exhausted as
Well, I mean, if you look at the last
interview that he done with
trigonometry, which we're going to be
speaking about today, his face was that
of a man who was tired that he was
justifying things. He was exhausted
himself.
>> It's not even that, bro. You know what
it is? People are just exhausted of
seeing his face. I mean, his face makes
people exhausted.
>> Yeah.
>> It's tiring looking at his face.
>> Yeah. And just hearing those same
excuses again and again. Just the g the
amount of gaslighting.
>> Yeah. It's just triggering for people.
>> Well, um, saying that, I mean, I was
surprised on trigonometry,
uh, that that video that they were kind
of hyping it up a couple of days before,
putting it on Twitter. This is a head of
state and they thought it was probably
going to get millions and millions of
views.
>> This is a this is a criminal.
>> Yeah.
>> This is a criminal in the midst of a
genocide. And these people are promoting
that video as if it's going to boost
their channel.
>> We only got 600,000 views.
>> That was pathetic. I mean for what it is
this man is meant to be a politician
ahead of is meant to be a head of state.
>> He's a he's a head of a failed Zionist
entity and his time is going to come
very soon inshallah.
>> But there are a few things in that
interview that really surprising
>> and there were admissions there were
confessions and I wanted to listen to
them me and you listen them together and
come back and respond in kind. So let's
listen to what Netanyahu
said.
>> And frankly, we also have to do
something about the the algorithms and
the social networks. This is uh this is
a big challenge. I don't want to uh I
don't want to dismiss it. But look, we
Jews have have been fighting and losing
the propaganda war for about 2500 years.
But what's different now is that we're
winning the ground war.
>> So what do you think of that, bro? I
think Satan Yahoo uh I think what he was
saying is it's so ironic because he's
making it seem like oh we got to do
something about this algorithm you see
um as if you haven't been doing
something about this algorithm since
even before October 7th it was magnified
more on October 7th but as if there's
only low IQ people will be watching that
going yeah you guys should do something
everyone knows that Israel has been
utilizing the media machine as much as
they can
>> and this comment is coming on the back
of that
>> after all of that investment they still
cannot rally people behind a genocide
taking place.
>> Do you know what it's it's interesting
cuz we were just looking at the famine
that they were calling it was like
staged and stuff like that and they made
these you know these uh videos about it
and etc. I mean now you've got ITV
coming out uh covering it, Channel 4
covering it, UN officials coming forward
and it's meant to be a fake news. But
look, the thing is what I found quite
interesting about this confession was
that he's admitting and he admits it
candidly within the interview by the way
that they are losing the PR war which
shows you the impact of the activists up
and down this country and many other
countries who are doing the great work
of raising awareness. He looked actually
like he was justifying himself. He had a
fragile ego. He was weakened by what was
going on and he was having to defend
himself. This is it shows you the
importance of social media activism. The
point that this guy is actually just
>> What is more weaker than you're you're
on the battlefield, but you care more
about a tweet. You care more about what
Grock says.
>> Yeah. Grock is the AI of X. And even
Grock, when people are asking Grock,
>> you know, what do you think about what's
going on? It is anti-Israel
>> to such a degree, it's biging up the
Austrian painter.
>> Mhm.
>> And then what?
>> And eventually they had to shut it down.
This this has happened at least twice if
not more times. They've shut it down and
then reprogrammed it. I thought AI was
supposed to be objective. I thought it
was supposed to be an accommodation of
the intellect and it's supposed to be
going towards a singularity, a time in
which humanity will do away with the
ways of the past and will go into
intellectual abyss.
>> Mhm.
>> But we're seeing the exact opposite
>> that human beings have had to shut it
down and then reprogram it. So I mean is
it really a uh an objective
intelligent source? No,
>> absolutely not.
>> To the contrary. And what I will say as
well
>> and and the the the finder of X as well,
Elon Musk, remember
>> when a lot of people were benefiting
from the posts of X, especially post
October the 7th, what did Elon Musk have
to do? He had to go over there and uh
[Music]
>> but what I will say um is this. I mean
we have seen here
>> um a double standard on both sides
because obviously this guy is talking
about on the one hand like you know
curtailing freedom of speech
trigonometry bro this is meant to be
like their whole mantra
>> is we are here to protect freedom of
speech and expression okay
>> these guys who both of them were very
weak in this interview but the the other
man not uh Constantine the other guy was
a little bit better but they're both
rubbish to be honest with you they're
both weak but he was a little bit
But what what they're meant to be is
protecting the mantra of freedom of
speech, etc. So this guy's talking about
manipulating algorithms. At that point,
they should have said, "Listen, we
believe in freedom of speech. That's our
belief. We understand they may be pro-
Israel and pro-Zionist and all that
stuff."
>> But when it comes
>> pretend,
>> Yeah. No, but that's one thing. But at
least with your own principles, defend
them.
>> Be consistent.
>> Be consistent. and say, "Okay, well,
actually, we believe freedom of speech
that even like Voltater said that I
disagree with what you say, but I will
die or I will defend to the death your
right to say it."
>> Voltera mentioned that as a liberal
thinker. I mean, instead of taking that
line, you know, and doing that, they're
like, you know, yeah, algorithm, we need
we who's this we that we need to change
the algorith. So, it's almost like he's
trying to enroll them into his program.
Do you know what I It's almost as if he
is fanning and adding fuel to this
conspiracy theory that that people say
that you've got certain people that have
more influence over the media. How can
somebody even dream of fixing the
algorithm, correcting the algorithm, or
making it more favorable if you don't
have that influence to begin with?
>> I'm going to I'm going to play a clip of
an individual. He used to be a senator.
Yeah,
>> he used to be a senator and he is
bragging.
>> Yeah, this is a US senator and he's
bragging that you know what, we have
control over meta and you know the
Google and this and that. You know, how
is it that we are still losing the war?
>> Let's take a look.
>> When you think about it, the masters of
the universe are Jews. You know, we
we've got Alman at ASI, we got
Zuckerberg, we got Sergey Brin, we got
the the group across the board, Yan
Combmes, you know, head of founded
WhatsApp. It's us. Now that
>> you know, you guys have seen that from
the horse's mouth himself. Let's deal
with some facts. Yeah. Now, there's
copious evidences that are there.
There's, you know, articles written that
are way more in depth, but we're just
going to dip your intellectual finger
into the ocean. So when it comes to
Google,
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. In 2022,
99 former unit 8200 agents were working
at Google.
>> It's the same one that they done the
rape of a man.
>> Say 200, isn't it?
>> This is a disable
>> 99 from that unit working at Google.
>> Unbelievable.
>> But you might say they're working at a
low level, maybe cleaning the toilets,
maybe, you know what I mean, just uh
doing what they're doing. But no, this
individual called Gabriel Godell.
>> Yeah. He's the head of strategy and
operations for Google research.
>> And he came to this position after 6
years in the military.
>> Unbelievable, bro.
>> And you guys can see where am I getting
this from, you know?
>> So, they're already trying to control
the algorithm.
>> It's Yeah, it's on their LinkedIn
profile. You guys can see it. You You're
going to see it on the screen right now
as I'm saying it. They're not even
hiding it.
>> You search for the name, you'll see it
on their LinkedIn profile. And this guy
is very senior in Google. Let's move on
to Meta. Yeah,
>> sure.
>> Meta owns Instagram.
>> Yeah.
>> Owns WhatsApp. So Meta is no small fish.
>> It's not.
>> Now, one of the most influential people
in Meta
>> is somebody called Emmy Palmer.
>> Sure.
>> And she is part of the oversight board.
This is like the Supreme Court.
>> That's the seniority
>> of the oversight board. Really? Yeah.
Yeah. And they are responsible for
>> what gets censored.
>> Ah,
>> what gets deleted
>> and what gets suppressed.
>> Oh, I see. So this individual that has
again worked in unit 8200 and was the
general director of Israeli ministry of
justice.
>> Unbelievable. So senior figures, people
that have held high positions there at
very, you know, um I mean objectively
vile positions of criminals, criminal
organization, anything to do with the
IDF. I'm sure we can agree.
>> Let's move on to Microsoft. Microsoft.
There's at least 166 former unit 8200
members there. And there was an
individual who's the senior product
manager at Microsoft called Mayan Mazic.
They were part of unit 8200.
>> This makes me sick.
>> So this is just a tip of the iceberg
when it comes to this.
I'll try to, you know, add some things
to the description if you want to read
more. But this, I'm telling you, the
level of gaslighting. Oh, you know, we
got to do something about this. We got
to do something. As if you're not doing
it already.
>> What a joke. And that's why the people
in the West
>> need to rise up and realize that their
institutions
have been colonized by Israel. they have
um in that interview I watched the
interview and at one point they were he
was speaking very candidly about what
happens in universities in the UK and in
other western countries and that shows
you that every person in universities
across the country that came out and
done things in support of the Gazin
cause that you've got here the
Luciferian one himself
>> uh testifying to the fact the
effectiveness
of your protests. And this may very well
be the last line of defense
>> for the Palestinian people and the most
important line because I assure you
these people who are narcissistic, who
are luciferian, who are diabolical, who
are megalomaniacal,
people like Netanyahu, they are also
hyper sensitive to criticism. They are
also incapable of taking it. For them,
losing 20,000 people in a war from their
own so-called soldiers may not be as bad
as getting 20,000 dislikes or 20,000
negative tweets. So you guys, we must
realize the fight is not over
>> and all of us are in this together. And
the activism we're doing not just in the
west but elsewhere as well is having an
impact.
>> Absolutely.
>> And the missiles are reaching the
target.
>> And with that we will conclude witham.
>> That's a good video is it?
[Music]
>> That was some good things I learned.
>> Hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again? Your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a masid, a da center.
Establishing a masid to convey the
message of Islam is one of the best
deeds a Muslim can do. There's a huge
need for it in Norway. You know this and
I know this. So that makes the reward
even greater. So give generously and
Allahawel will give you even more.